♪ ♪
>> Harold: HARD WORK ALWAYS
PAYS OFF.
SOME NYU STUDENTS ARE JUST TOO
GOOD FOR THAT.
AN ORGANIC CHEMISTRY PROFESSOR
CLAIMS HE WAS FIRED BECAUSE
STUDENTS COMPLAINED HIS CLASS
WAS JUST TOO DIFFICULT.
STUDENT SIGNED A PETITION
BLAMING HIS TEACHING STYLE FOR
THEIR POOR GRADES.
THE PROFESSOR THINKS IT'S THE
STUDENTS' FAULT.
"THEY WEREN'T COMING TO CLASS,
THAT'S FOR SURE.
THEY WEREN'T WATCHING THE VIDEOS
AND THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO ANSWER
THE QUESTIONS."
NYU SAYS JONES WAS NOT FIRED
BECAUSE OF COMPLAINTS WAS ON A A
ONE YEAR CONTRACT WAS NOT
RENEWED.
GREG.
>> Greg: TRUTH IS SOMEWHERE IN
THE MIDDLE.
HE'S BEEN SEMIRETIRED SINCE
2007.
HE'S 84.
THERE IS THAT.
STUDENTS ARE LAZY AND I'VE GOT
TO ADMIT CHEMISTRY IS REALLY
HARD.
IT IS HARD.
YOU KNOW THE DEFINITION OF HARD
IS?
WHEN THERE'S NO WAY YOU CAN B.S.
AN ANSWER.
THIS IS WHY PEOPLE LIKE ME AT
ALL OF US HERE ENDED UP IN THE
LIBERAL ARTS OR HUMANITIES.
WE COULDN'T --
WE COULD NEVER SOLVE FOR X.
WE COULD DEFINITELY B.S. OUR WAY
FOREVER ON WHY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY I CAN'T
FIGURE OUT THE ANSWER.
MAYBE I CAN TALK MY WAY OUT OF
IT.
YOU CAN'T WITH CHEMISTRY.
WE NEED TO MAKE HARD TOPICS MORE
ATTRACTIVE.
THEY ARE PRETTY AMAZING.
>> Harold: JUDGE, ARE YOU
READY?
>> Jeanine: ORGANIC CHEMISTRY,
THAT'S REALLY, REALLY TOUGH.
KIDS WERE DOING IT VIRTUALLY.
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO STUDY.
THE GUY WROTE THE TEXTBOOK.
THE GUYS APPARENTLY LEGENDARY.
OUGHT TO SUE THEM FOR AGE
DISCRIMINATION.
>> Martha: ORGANIC CHEMISTRY
IS A CLASSIC KEEPS PEOPLE OUT OF
MED SCHOOL.
IF YOU CAN'T HANDLE ORGANIC
CAMP, SOMEONE PEOPLE SAY I WAS
GOING TO BE A DOCTOR BUT I GOT
WASHED OUT CHEM INORGANIC.
IT SEPARATES THE DOCTORS FROM
THE NONDOCTORS.
I WOULD BE IN THE NONDOCTOR
CATEGORY.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS, YOU GET
WEEDED OUT.
THEY GET WEEDED OUT BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T ORGANIC CHEM HANDLE.
>> Greg: IS ORGANIC CHEMISTRY
BETTER THAN THE OTHER
CHEMISTRIES?
ALL THE ORGANIC THINGS?
>> Jesse: YOU'VE GOT TO WEED
OUT THE IDIOTS.
IF I GET SURGERY, I GO IN FOR
TRANSPLANTS TRANSPLANT AND THE
STUPID DOCTOR WITH A FREE PASS
ON ORGANIC CHEMISTRY MESSES UP
AND GIVES ME A SEX CHANGE
OPERATION I LEAVE THE OPERATING
TABLE AND I AM LIKE THIS.
I YOU CAN'T HAVE MISTAKES LIKE
THAT.
>> Jeanine: LIKE WHAT?
>> Jesse: YOU KNOW WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT.
AN ACCIDENTAL SEX CHANGE
OPERATION.
IF YOU GO INTO GRAD SCHOOL,
YOU'RE RIGHT, THERE'S NO RIGHT
OR WRONG ANSWER.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
IT'S ALL GROUP PROJECTS.
YOU CAN COAST.
LAW SCHOOL IS DIFFICULT BECAUSE
IF YOU MESS UP, YOU CAN GET A
CLIENT IN PRISON.
MED SCHOOL, IF YOU MESS UP, YOU
CAN DIE ON THE OPERATING TABLE
OR HAVE AN ACCIDENTAL
SEX CHANGE.
>> Jeanine: DOCTORS BURY THEIR
MIST